everyone this is Kevin from the test
website comm today are gonna be looking
at game six from the 2014 World Chess
Championships between Magnus Kraus and
the reigning champion and vision on the
Challenger up until this point we are
tied both players have one win apiece
and the rest of the games are drawn game
six we're gonna see Magnus Carlsen
playing the white pieces fishing on
defending with the black pieces when we
go into Game seven
- Crossan will actually have the white
pieces again and then we will flip flop
going through Game 12 where Vichy and on
will close it out with the white pieces
so very important right now that Magnus
Carlsen has some good games in here both
six which are gonna be looking at in
game seven which is gonna be coming up
here in a couple days because he knows
that this is his chance to really go out
in front with the white pieces maybe
potentially get some big wins in here
and really put Vichy and on and it's
tough spot so we'll go ahead and get
started
pawn to e4 similar to what we've kind of
seen this whole tournament
- Carlsen playing those aggressive
openings with pawn to e4 vision on
opting to kind of go for that pawn to d4
bishi decides to go and play with the
aggressive defense that he has chosen so
far and that is the Sicilian offense
which is always good to see that he's
coming to attack Knight to f3 pawn to e6
pretty common moves for the Sicilian
defense we now see the con variation so
pawn here to a6
controlling the square here on a b5 so
you know the the bishop can't come here
also the knight can't come over here to
b5 either pawn to c4 so just starting to
put pressure on at this central light
square right here Knight to f6 Knight
here to c3 Bishop to b4 developing the
minor piece getting rid of to castle on
the King side if he wants to Queen here
to d3 so you know Magnus Carlsen he
could try to get pretty creative and
castle on the Queen side but more than
likely in this set up he's going to
castle on the King side
Knight here to c6 development move we do
see an exchange off the board which we
don't always see and now after the pawn
takes here on c6 it it's an interesting
situation that doesn't always
come up but we do see these players
decide to go ahead and exchange their
Queens off the board very early on so
vision on can no longer castle so he's
going to be looking to even get his King
involved into the game typically when
your opponent's Queen comes off the
board it's a little safer for your Kings
to go ahead and get towards the middle
of the board maybe join into the attack
now both sides do have a lot of material
on board so they may want to exchange
some material off before they get too
aggressive with their King but Magnus
Carlsen right now is the only player
left that can castle as King we now see
the palm pushing forward to e5 it was
being attacked right now
now the Knights going to come back here
to the 7 Bishop u2 at 4 adding another
defender also opening up the door if
magnus carlsen wants to castle on the
queenside machine on decides he wants to
go ahead and give magnus carlsen a
double pawns here on the c file and then
the king to c7 so the sides you know as
he looked at both sides of the board
machine on decides that the Queen side
is where he wants to go ahead and try to
kind of push for in advantage the King
side he doesn't really have any of his
material over here and so because he
wants to attack on the Queen side he's
gonna go ahead and starts getting his
King involved as much as possible magnus
carlsen decides to go ahead and push on
the King side so pawn to h4 and if we
kind of look at both sides what they're
looking to do here we do see manage
cross him with the double bishop pair
which is always good it's somewhat of a
semi closed game so Magnus Carlsen
definitely wants to get a lot of the
pawns off the board so his bishops
pretty much have free rein to control
the entire board he also has double
pawns here on the C file which is not
really great if he maybe had a pawn on
the D file this would not be nearly as
bad so definitely something that vision
on can maybe attack later on in the game
Magnus Carlsen still is the only one
that can castle but really it's not
gonna do too much for him to castle on
the King side potentially if he wants to
go ahead and maybe double up with this
rooks over here on the Queen side maybe
try to control this semi-open file on
the B file this open file here on the D
foul he has those options on the other
side vision on he wants to try to keep
it somewhat semi closed his Knights
gonna be a lot better
if there's a lot of pawns on board it
can kind of jump all over the place
more than likely he's gonna want to get
this lied to her Bishop off the board
right now it's not doing too much it's
kind of actually blocked off especially
by this pawn here on e6 so unless he can
get it involved over on the Queen side
he would really like to exchange that
off the board both of these players are
gonna try to look to get there rooks
involved they usually want these to be
pretty aggressive in these type of
openings they don't want them to just
kind of stand back and just defend pawns
they really want them to be in the
center of the board and pushing for an
advantage we now see pawn here to b6
pawn here to h5 the next move is pretty
interesting when I saw it it didn't seem
that crazy to me but pretty much all the
commentators even a lot of the
grandmasters that were kind of giving
commentary on the side thought that pawn
to h6 really put vision on it tough spot
because this pawn here on g7 was going
to come under fire and it would be very
very difficult for vision on to have to
deal with this and worry about anything
else on the board if you want to push
her an advantage on the Queen side or do
much else because again he was gonna
have to worry about the square here on
g7 so as soon as we did see this h2
Excel was pretty interesting Magnus
Carlsen actually started attacking it
right away so it was something that
Magnus Carlsen sallman so we see the
castle on the Queen side again it
doesn't really matter where the Kings
are we don't have to worry that there's
not a lot of safety there's a lot of air
in front of this King right here on c1
but this is really just a way to get
this rook involved very very quickly so
work here to d3 getting ready to swing
over here to the g3 square and start to
attack this pawn here on g7 pawn here to
c5 opening up the door for this light
square bishop to control a lot this long
diagonal right here
we're over here to g3 as we talked about
and now this writ comes over here to GA
it's very important to make sure that
you defend with your rooks properly we
don't want to see vision on play rook
here to g7 this light square bishop
could eventually come here to d3 and
then bishop here to h7 that's gonna be
very very difficult for vichy not to
deal with so he correctly defends with
his rook here on g8 coming from a8 we
now see the last minor piece
magnus carlsen come into the game with
bishop here to d3 the Knights gonna come
back here to FA trying to mitigate some
of the risk over here on the Kings side
Bishop back here to e3 and the mission
on plays pawn here to g6
starting to realize from fishing on hey
just didn't want to have to deal with
the square here on g7 his opponent would
just put a lot of pressure on it so now
that his knight back here on f8 and his
rook both can kind of defend this square
right here with the pawn here on f7 and
now's a good time to go ahead and push
forward so after the exchange that's
gonna come here to g6 recapture and then
we see of the row come up here to h5
defending the square here on e5 but also
just trying to stay pretty active for
Magnus Carlsen so far up into this game
Magnus Carlsen has definitely been the
aggressor Vishy Anand been a little bit
more defensively minded set so far and
so Magnus Carlsen wants to keep that
going so far fishing on right now trying
to hold on making sure it doesn't do
anything too crazy
and then hopefully Magnus Carlsen can
make a mistake and he can come in and
possibly take a point away so now we see
Bishop here to c6 Bishop coming back
here to see to King here to b7 small
incremental moves in the game that both
sides decided was going to be good for
them rook up here to g4 defending the
square here on c4 so just a little bit
better pawn here to a5 so fishing on
realizing that it's going to be tough on
the Kings side to really push for an
advantage so maybe in the future decides
he wants to push on the Queen side so
pawn here to h5 Bishop here to d1
recover here to d8 attacking controlling
this long open foul right here now
Magnus Carlsen had a few options for a
mirror he decides just to bring his
Bishop back here to see - he really
didn't have to though
he doesn't even have to move his his
Bishop at all if he doesn't want to but
he could have easily played Bishop here
to e2 I probably like this a little bit
better better it controls the square
here on c4 and you know really this this
rook just isn't doing too much even if
the rook wanted to be pretty aggressive
and come down here to d3 it's still
controlling that square right now but he
decides to go and play Bishop here to c2
and then the birds can swing back over
here to a g8 the next move was pretty
critical in this match and Magnus
Carlsen makes a huge blunder
he plays King here to d2 and afterwards
he said King to d2 is really the only
move
that he can make which puts him in a
very bad spot which is interesting that
of all the moves he found the one that
was possibly the worst and this is bad
for a number of reasons but it was
interesting for those who actually got
to watch the match as soon as magnus
carlsen played this he just put his head
down and kind of shook his head of
disgust he realized as soon as he had
done it that he had made a huge mistake
they even asked him in an interview
afterwards did you just not even try to
put on a poker face and he said he was
just so disgusted with the move that he
had a horrible poker face he couldn't
just hide his emotion at all so from
here it's pretty easy
fishing on can just come in here to e5
and this is dangerous because you know
it's attacking both this rook here on g4
and also this pawn here and the pawns
very dangerous as well because if it's
taken then the King here on d2 is
checked but now we do see an exchange on
the board and then this knight can come
in here to a c4 all of a sudden the
Kings up comes up here to d3 the King
can the Knights now gonna come to b2
attacking as well the King can come back
here the rook can take here on g8 the
rook can swing up here to h6 if he wants
to and then Bishop here to b5 and all of
a sudden Vichy and on is in a really
really good spot on this board
unfortunately for Vichy and on the very
easy move that we all kind of thought
everyone just thought that he would
immediately do it
he actually immediately played something
else he took about 30 seconds which is
pretty fast at this high level of play
he played pawn to a4 and this was
another huge blunder maybe even bigger
than Magnus Carlsen and this definitely
was a turning point so he had again in
this game afterwards Vichy and I just
said he didn't realize what a gift his
opponent had given him and sometimes
when you don't take a when you're not
looking for a gift you don't take that
gift so upon to a4 allows Magnus Carlsen
to play King here to e2 and it's very
important to look at this you know if we
come back here and say okay the King
doesn't come here to d2 let's say the
King just comes here to d1 because they
asked Magnus Carlsen later you know
you said King 2d2 is a massive blunder
and everyone would agree with that but
where would you go instead he said you
know King - D - that's fine because
after night here to e5 then we see the
exchange here on g8 the exchange back
now the rook can come over here to see
five because there can't be that
in-between move you can't have that
night here to see for what you could
before because again that would give
check to his opponents that King right
now is no longer on d2 so we can't do
that and all of a sudden things are
gonna go very very badly for him Magnus
Carlsen is definitely going to be up in
this position even after Brooke comes
down here Magnus Carlsen is gonna be
doing very very well so that one subtle
move of just coming over here to d1
instead of d2 would have made all the
difference but in the game Magnus
Carlsen played King here to d2 vision on
really just had to play Knight here to
e5 he would have gone on to maybe not a
easy one it was still pretty tough
position but definitely a commanding
lead he would not have lost any points
for you had done that in the game though
made a huge blunder back-to-back
blunders one of the first times they
said that there's been such huge
blunders back-to-back in such a high
level of play pawn here - a for Magnus
Carlsen then immediately plays Kings to
e2 recognizing that he needs to get his
King off of the square on d2 so that the
knight can't come over here to c4 with
that check and gain momentum in that
tempo on his opponent we now see pawn
here to a3 again not doing too much pawn
to f3 trying to make sure that he has
protection on this rook but also wants
to make sure he's defending the square
here on g2 because of this LightSquared
Bishop is adding pressure there rook
over here to the 8th trying to control
this long file King to e1 rook to the 7
getting ready to double up if he needs
to Bishop back here to see one other
work so swinging over here to a8 it's
not clear how he's gonna add too much
pressure over here on the Queen side
Bishop over here to a4 vision on he even
said it at the end he just started
playing poorly because mentally he had
just been dominated but that mood just
completely destroyed his game now the
bishops forced to come back here and
then the bishops gonna come up here take
that material off the
all of a sudden the reverse can start
gobbling up material magnus carlsen
starts to gain even more material
advantage and so after just a few moves
we now see vision on resign in this
position magnus carlsen up quite a bit
of material and more centralized King so
gonna be a pretty easy game to end out
here for Magnus Carlsen Magnus Carlsen
wasn't even too happy about this win at
the end just because he made such a huge
blunder and even said this could have
cost me the championship that one to
move King to d2 could have cost me in
the tyre championship but he did say he
was relieved more than anything Vichy
and on just looked completely
heartbroken he realized that he passed
up maybe the biggest opportunity that
he's had in a very long time especially
against Magnus Carlsen who doesn't make
very many mistakes especially at that
point in the match so all of a sudden
congratulations Magnus Carlsen he is now
up a point on Vichy and on and the next
match or the next game Vichy and on will
have to play black again and Magnus
Carlsen is going to be coming back with
the white pieces so we have six more
games left in the series we've done six
so far so 12 total for the World
Championship Magnus Carlsen playing
extremely well
- that blunder he is still playing
extremely good poker so hopefully he can
keep it up machine ons gonna have to
come up with something different or he's
going to be runner up yet again so
hopefully you guys enjoyed hopefully you
learned something I'll see you guys in
the next video thanks for watching